Olá hoje eu vou abordar um tema que Tem
se tornado cada vez mais comum nas
consultas médicas o cansaço muitos
pacientes chegam relatando uma falta de
energia persistente uma sensação de
cansaço que diminui significativamente
sua produtividade e bem-estar ao longo
do dia muitos de nós experimentamos esse
tipo de cansaço não é aquele esgotamento
total que nos prende à cama mas é um
cansaço persistente que nos acompanha
dia após dia tornando as tarefas mais
afiadoras do que deveriam ser e o que
está por trás desse cansaço constante
que não nos derruba completamente mas
nos impede de viver com a energia que
desejamos e mais importante eu vou
compartilhar com vocês quatro maneiras
eficazes de combater esse cansaço de
reacender aquela Faísca de energia que
todos nós merecemos ter em nossas vidas
pessoal é importante ressaltar
contudo que se após essas mudanças o
cansaço persistir ou se você suspeita
que ele pode est está relacionado a
condições de saúde mais sérias busque
ajuda médica isso é essencial por
exemplo problemas de tireoide com uma
disfunção tireoidiana não tratada outra
condição pouco conhecida mas igualmente
importante é o desequilíbrio adrenal
Este é um desequilíbrio hormonal
relacionado às glândulas suprarrenais
que podem afetar profundamente nossos
níveis de energia a depressão por
exemplo não apenas afeta o nosso humor
mas também pode levar uma fadiga
profunda alterações no sono como Insônia
ou apnea do Sono condições como anemia
ou problemas intestinais todos podem
levar uma sensação de cansaço constante
e claro aos impactos dos equilíbrios de
açúcar no sangue se você está lidando
com a resist insulina pré-diabetes ou
diabetes isso pode afetar
significativamente seus níveis de
energia então se você se identifica com
um cansaço que parece não ter fim mesmo
com esforço para combatê-lo é crucial
consultar o médico ou uma médica Então
vamos pra primeira maneira de resolver o
cansaço vamos falar sobre uma solução
simples porém muitas vezes esquecida a
hidratação adequada pessoal a
desidratação pode ter um impacto
significativo em como nós nos sentimos
ao longo do dia quando falamos em
desidratação não apenas Estamos nos
referindo a uma sede extrema estamos
falando sobre não fornecer ao nosso
corpo a quantidade de água de que ele
precisa para funcionar de forma
otimizada muitas vezes quando sentimos
sede nosso corpo já está em um estado
leve desidratação você pode estar
pensando mas eu bebo líquidos o dia todo
no entanto é importante saber que
bebidas como refrigerante e bidas
alcoólicas podem na verdade contribuir
para desidratação o mesmo Vale pro
excesso de exercício sem reposição
adequada de líquidos e uso de certos
medicamentos e se você tem diabetes
prestar atenção a sua hidratação é ainda
mais crucial a desidratação não só
aumenta o açúcar do sangue mas também
impede que suas células funcionem
corretamente aqui está algo que talvez
você não saiba nossas células precisam
de água para funcionar sem água
suficiente elas não conseguem realizar
suas funções vitais Além disso os
eletrólitos como sódio potássio cloreto
e
bicarbonato são essenciais para manter
energia do nosso corpo eles ajudam a
regular a eletricidade que mantém nossos
órgãos e células funcionando
especialmente em partes do corpo
altamente conectadas eletricamente Como
é o cérebro o coração e o sistema
nervoso e músculos eles precisam de água
pessoal quando estamos desidratados isso
afeta a viscosidade do nosso sangue e
consequentemente a eficiência com que o
nosso coração bombeia oxigênio e
nutrientes pelo corpo isso pode levar a
sintomas como cansaço exaustão letargia
névoa cerebral fraqueza muscular e
dificuldade de concentração Então qual é
a solução a primeira maneira de combater
o cansaço é garantir que você esteja
bebendo água suficientemente preste
atenção à quantidade de água que você
ingere e a aprenda a calcular a
quantidade ideal Com base no seu peso
altura intensidade e atividade física
lembre-se de beber água regularmente ao
longo do dia pelo menos até às 7 horas
da noite na descrição desse vídeo eu vou
deixar um link para um conteúdo
detalhado sobre a importância da
hidratação E como você pode se
certificar de estar bebendo a quantidade
adequada de água agora vamos falar sobre
a segunda maneira de combater o cansaço
uma estratégia que exige determinação
mas traz Recompensas incríveis superar o
estilo de vida sedentário muitos de nós
vivemos um estilo de vida onde a maior
parte do dia é passada sentada
trabalhando em frente ao computador
dirigindo ou relaxando no sofá esse
padrão de inatividade faz com que o
nosso corpo se acostume com estado de
baixa energia forçando-nos a permanecer
nesse ciclo é como quando tentamos
perder peso o nosso corpo pode de
Resistir às mudanças iniciais tentando
voltar ao estado anterior da mesma
maneira romper com sedentarismo requer
um esforço consciente para mudar os
nossos hábitos viver de forma sedentária
pode levar a uma série de problemas
dores de pescoço costas rígidas dor de
cabeça e claro aumento do cansaço e da
Fadiga mas aqui está boa notícia você
pode começar pequeno não é necessário ir
direto paraa academia ou iniciar uma
rotina intensa de exercícios o truque É
incorporar movimentos leves e frequentes
ao seu dia se você trabalha sentado
levante-se a cada hora movimente os
braços o pescoço as pernas esses
pequenos movimentos ao longo do dia
podem fazer uma grande diferença à
medida que você começa a se mover mais
vai notar uma melhora nas dores um
aumento na
motivação na redução do cansaço o
exercício regular ajuda a equilibrar os
hormônios melhora a resistência à
insulina e promove um sono de melhor
qualidade esses pequenos movimentos
podem evoluir para atividades mais
estruturadas com musculação pilates ou
caminhadas diárias o exercício físico
faz Maravilhas pro nosso corpo ele
libera endorfinas aumenta a resistência
melhora o humor fortalece os músculos e
queima a gordura é uma ferramenta
poderosa na luta contra o cansaço então
se você está lutando contra o cansaço
desse primeiro passo mesmo que seja
pequeno cada movimento conta pessoal a
terceira estratégia para superar o
cansaço é ajustar nossa alimentação Eu
Acredito que muitos de vocês já
suspeitavam que a dieta desempenha um
papel muito importante no nosso nível de
energia uma dieta rica em carboidratos
refinados alimentos Ultra processados e
açúcares pode ser um dos principais
vilões do cansaço ao consumir esses
alimentos não estamos fornecendo a nosso
corpo os nutrientes essenciais para
manter a nossa energia estamos falando
de gorduras saudáveis proteínas de
qualidade e os nutrientes vitais
encontrados nos vegetais uma dieta pobre
pode elevar a deficiências nutricionais
a falta de vitaminas como a vitamina B12
ou minerais como ferro magnésio potássio
e Zinco pode causar o agravamento do
cansaço como uma ferritina baixa mesmo
se anemia instalada pode deixá-los
esgotado as vitaminas do complexo B são
fundamentais paraa transformação dos
alimentos energia elas atuam na
conversão de glicos aminoácidos e ácidos
grassos em combustível que nossas
células podem utilizar sem níveis
adequados essas vitaminas nosso
metabolismo não funciona eficientemente
levando a sensação de cansaço e falta de
energia e quanto ao álcool embora a beb
regularmente possa parecer relaxante à
primeira vista o consumo excessivo de
álcool pode esgotar o corpo de
nutrientes vitais especialmente a
vitamina B1 a tiamina então a
deficiência da B1 tiamina está
diretamente relacionado ao aumento de
fadiga e da fraqueza para combater o
cansaço é fundamental equilibrar a dieta
concentre-se em alimentos que sustentam
sua energia de forma consistente que são
as gorduras saudáveis as proteínas de
alta qualidade e uma variedade de
vegetais ricos em nutrientes pessoal
além das causas físicas do cansaço é
vital reconhecer o papel do estresse
mental e emocional na nossa energia
diária o cansaço não é apenas uma
questão de corpo mas também de mente
estresse ansiedade e carga emocional
intensa podem ser tão exaustivos quanto
o esforço físico quando nossa mente está
constantemente preocupada concentrada em
problemas ou rodeada por negatividade
nosso corpo sente os efeitos Pense nas
pessoas ao seu redor está cercado por
indivíduos invejosos negativos ou
aqueles que constantemente drenam sua
energia podem levar a um estado de
fadiga constante isso é um reflexo de
como o ambiente e as interações sociais
afetam diretamente nossa saúde mental e
consequentemente a nossa energia Além
disso O stresse emocional pode causar
perturbações no sono muitas pessoas sob
estresse acham difícil conseguir um sono
restaurador o que por sua vez leva a um
maior cansaço durante o dia esse ciclo
de estresse e sono inadequado pode ser
extremamente prejudicial pra saúde geral
é importante fazer uma autoanálise Como
está a harmonia em sua casa as pessoas
com quem você convive estão contribuindo
pro seu bem-estar ou estão esgotando a
sua energia e o seu ambiente de trabalho
está alinhado com suas necessidades
emocionais e mentais reconhecer a
influência do ambiente ao seu redor é o
primeiro passo para combater o estresse
se você identificar que pessoas tóxicas
estão drenando sua energia pode ser
necessário fazer mudanças difíceis mas
que são essenciais relações negativas
não apenas causam cansaço mas também
podem agravar ou desencadear doenças
sérias buscar estratégias de
gerenciamento de estresse como meditação
ter Apia ou simplesmente passar tempo em
ambientes que trazem paz e alegria com
pessoas positivas e que agregam
qualidade e felicidade a sua vida pode
ser fundamental para restaurar os seus
níveis de energia muito obrigado pela
sua atenção um grande abraço um beijo no
seu coração Você é fera